Let's do some scale and indirect
measurement problems.
So they say use the scale
diagram to the right to
determine-- I think this is
the scale diagram they're
talking-- it's really
above the question.
And they want to determine--
let's see first, the length of
the helicopter.
When they say the scale diagram,
you notice this
helicopter looks pretty small.
I don't know how big your screen
is, but looks maybe,
one or two inches, depending
on what resolution you're
watching this video on.
But they're saying this
helicopter is
much bigger than that.
They're saying just this little
distance right here--
just that little distance, that
little white box there--
that's actually a foot on
the real helicopter.
So what they're able to do is to
draw a small version of the
helicopter and essentially give
us a ruler and tell us
that that little distance
is equivalent to a foot.
And this whole distance right
here, that whole distance
right there, is equivalent to
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 feet.
Did I get that right?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
So this thing is equal
to 7 feet.
So given that, let's try to
answer their question.
So the first one, the length
of the helicopter.
So that's from cabin to tail, is
that distance right there.
Let's see how many of
these things it is.
So if I take that right there,
let me see if I can copy and
paste that.
So if I-- let's see, if I copy
it and then I paste it,
there's one right there.
One.
Edit, paste.
Two right there.
And then we get not
quite three.
Almost three, but not quite.
We get about that far.
So it looks like about-- so
this right here is-- this
right here is 7 feet.
That right there is
another 7 feet.
And I know that, because
that is 7 feet
according to the scale.
And then this looks like
we got about that far.
So it looks like this is
maybe another 5 feet,
if I were to estimate.
Actually, if we went to go all
the way to the end of the
tail-- if we went to the end
of here-- it actually looks
like another 7 feet.
We actually complete
three 7 feets.
So I would say that part a,
I would go it's 27 feet.
Sorry, not 27.
21 feet.
7 feet times 3 is equal to 21.
I'd go part one.
Because if you go all the way
to this tippy, tippy of the
rear rotor right there, then
you're going to get 21.
And you're going to get three
of these lengths.
Let's do part b.
The height of the helicopter.
Floor to rotors.
So from here-- from
floor to rotors.
Well, I'll go from down
here to the rotors.
They might be talking about
this floor, but who knows?
So what is this distance
right here in feet?
What is that distance?
We could just eyeball
a little bit.
They didn't give us
a vertical scale.
We could just-- this scale looks
like about that high.
So that would be about 7 feet.
Let me copy and paste that.
So let me copy it.
Let me paste it.
So that would be 7
feet right there.
Then if I were do another one,
we're getting about another
1/2 of 7 feet.
So that'd be another
3 and 1/2 feet.
So I would say that this
is 7 right there.
And then we get about
3 and 1/2.
So 7 plus 3 and 1/2
is 10.5 feet.
The length of one main rotor--
and I think the main rotor--
they're talking about this
length right there.
That length right there.
That is the length of
one main rotor.
Or actually, this length
right here.
That is the length of
one main rotor.
And let's compare it to
this scale over here.
So let's compare it.
That's 7 feet.
So let's copy it.
And then let's paste it.
I lost it.
So let me copy it.
Let me copy and then paste.
So that's one length.
So we want one rear rotor.
So that's 7 feet right there.
7 feet right there.
And we can do another one.
The important thing is to
get the idea of it.
You don't have to get the
exact measurement.
We're not about to go out there
and build a helicopter.
So what is this length?
We have 7 feet.
And then we have 1, 2, 3,
about another 4 feet.
So I would go with part c, I'd
go with 11 feet for one rotor
if we're getting to see
this actually head on.
Maybe it's a little bit longer
if it's at an angle.
But that gives us our
general idea.
Actually it looks a little
bit longer than that.
But the idea is as long as you
understand how I'm using the
scale is the main thing.
The width of the cabin.
So here-- that's the cabin
width right there.
This distance.
That distance right there
is the cabin width.
And if we compare it to this
right here, we already said
that this right here
is 7 feet roughly.
Edit, copy, edit, paste.
So that is 7 feet.
That looks like about the
width of the cabin.
It's a good estimate.
So the width of the cabin,
I would say, is 7 feet.
And then find the diameter
of the rear rotor system.
The rear rotor system
is this right here.
That is the rear rotor system.
So if we were to copy and paste
our 7 foot lengths--
actually, let me copy and
paste the actual ruler.
So this is our actual ruler.
So how long is the rear
rotor system?
Let's look at our ruler.
Looks like 1, 2, 3, 4 feet
is my best estimate.
So I'd say the diameter of the
rear rotor system is 4 feet.
So you might have already known
how to do this, but now
you have a good sense.
Look, this is telling us that
this little distance on the
picture is actually equivalent
to a foot.
And you just compare it to the
actual picture, and you know
how big the actual
helicopter is.
That's all that's
going on there.
Let's do another scale and
indirect measurement problem.
So it says on a Sunday morning,
the shadow of the
Empire State Building
is 600 feet long.
At the same time, the shadow
of a yard stick, which is 3
feet long, is 1 foot
5 1/4 inches.
How high is the Empire
State Building?
So we could say height of Empire
to length of shadow.
So length of the shadow of
Empire should be equal to
taking the length of a yard
stick, so height of yard
stick-- I'm assuming that
they're pointing up the yard
stick like a skyscraper-- height
of yard stick divided
by length of shadow
of yard stick.
Now this problem looks a little
bit hairier because we
have feet here, and then we
have 1 foot 5 1/4 inches.
And you do everything
in inches.
And you do everything in feet.
And the interesting
thing is here.
You can look at the units.
As long as we calculate this in
feet and we calculate this
in feet down here, these units
are going to cancel out.
If you have x feet divided by
600 feet, in this case, the
feet are going to cancel out.
You'll have a unit-less
quantity.
So it's really just going
to be a pure ratio.
Same thing here.
You can do it in feet.
Or you can do it in inches.
And you could actually do this
in feet and do this side in
inches, because you get
feet divide by feet.
The feet cancel out.
The inches cancel out.
So they stay unit-less.
So it actually becomes a lot
easier when you can keep the
right side in inches and
you can keep the
left side in feet.
So let's say the height of the
Empire State Building is x.
So we could say x feet over
the length of the shadow.
The shadow of the Empire State
Building is 600 feet.
Over 600 feet is equal to the
length of a yard stick
standing up.
Or the height of a yard stick.
Let's do it in inches.
3 feet long is 36 inches.
36 inches.
And I want to show you that
the units work out.
36 inches divided by the
length of its shadow.
1 foot 5 1/4 inches.
What's that?
One foot is 12 inches.
12 plus 5 1/4 is 17 1/4.
Or 17.25 inches.
And notice the units
cancel out.
Feet divided by feet.
Inches divided by inches.
So they just become
pure ratios.
x/600 is equal to 36/17.25.
The reason why I could use feet
here and inches here is
because the units cancel out.
I want to make that very,
very, very clear.
Now we can just cross multiply,
which is essentially
just multiplying both sides of
the equation by 600 and 17.25.
So 17.25 times x is going to
be equal to 36 times 600.
And then we can divide
both sides by 17.25.
So x is equal to 36 times
600 over 17.25.
And let's get the
calculator out.
So x is equal to 36 times
600 divided by
17.25 is equal to 1,252.2.
Let's just round it.
So x is equal to 1,252.2 feet,
which is almost 1/4 of a mile.
So the Empire State Building
is pretty high.
But this is pretty neat, because
this is something that
you could actually do.
You could actually measure the
shadow of a skyscraper and
then you could actually
measure the
shadow of a yard stick.
And then doing that, you can
actually figure out the height
of a skyscraper.
Which is pretty neat, because
if you didn't know how to do
this math, you'd have to get
into a helicopter, and drop a
huge-- I mean it'd be a much
harder thing to do.
So hopefully, you found that
pretty interesting.